okay sorry first of all i think there's
going to be a lot of confusion
we just jumped right in here let's uh
yeah let's let's let's
dial it back a bit let's let's let's go
back a bit do you want to introduce
yourself to audiences who don't know
what are you doing
what do you do why are you wearing it
because to someone who doesn't because
there's
someone who doesn't know who ladybird is
they're probably just thinking who's
this white guy in a dress
random aussie you just joined the trash
chase just i don't know anything
i i want to come into this blind i
wanted to hear and meet you and
experience everything so i know
absolutely
nothing about you i am conor's biggest
fan
has made me so happy in the short time
i've known him um
let me introduce myself watch this i'll
do it like where uh like we're on tv
this is channel seven right here ready
my name's ladybeard i'm a heavy metal
singer and pro wrestler from australia
currently based in japan today i'm
thrilled to be talking to my friends the
questions
it's very creepy this is
that was like australian like news
documentary narration voice yes
it was wasn't it yeah so but i didn't go
up at the end of my sentence
the way i potentially should have like
every australian dog here in australian
media
where in japan there's no need to talk
about the wonderful nation of australia
from which
uh both joseph and i hail we get we can
get to that though we can get together
so how does
a heavy metal singer and a pro wrestler
wait which one were you first
dresser i was first a cross dresser
oh really then became a cross-dressing
pro wrestler right and then became a
cross-dressing
wrestling heavy metal what what what is
what is the journey
i feel like you're saying these steps so
casually i'm trying to break these down
that's like that's like someone being
like i was a straight man
and then i went a straight man who
became an astrophysicist
and then i became a straight man who did
astrophysicists and does gardening
everything
i feel like are you not those things yes
i thought that's what this was yeah i
feel like there's a story that gets for
us from point a to point b but i'm just
not seeing it so
i okay i used to live in uh the city of
hong kong
and i was an actor and a voice actor and
approach
how did you get to hong kong
i went through acting school in
australia okay to be an actor
okay but that's mainly what acting
school's for yes yes
mainly makes sense but i also am a
martial artist
okay and so what happened was i then i
moved
from adelaide that's where i'm from
which as joey will know is a small city
yes
to melbourne right joey will know is a
big city
a big earth a bigger city this isn't a
child series
and so i was training in in hong kong
style
um like cinematic action with this
aussie dude who was on jackie chan's
stunt team right oh wow so i was on his
stunt team right
and um basically there's no work factors
in australia at the time
so i'm there and i'm auditioning and
things and i'm auditioning against like
aussie celebrities and things so there's
no way as a school leaver i'm going to
get a bloody joy right so this stunt
dude i was training with he was like you
should go to hong kong
because worst case scenario you'll go
there you'll get a bit of work because
it's easier because you're a foreigner
so you've got less competition then you
can come back here and be more
employable
right go to auditions right and they'd
be like yeah you're good
but you need experience cash 22 how are
you going to get experience
that's right so it's like they tell me
somehow you have to get experience we're
not going to help you
all right so anyway so yeah i went to
hong kong playing just do a couple of
movies and then come home
i ended up staying six years
so you say that so casually there was
much more work to be had in hong kong
than there was at home
right right like you just stayed around
the mates
just in case you just kept getting
working hard yeah well there was much
more to do there yeah there's much more
to do there
but so this is true so i went in uh
2006.
um i had a brief stint when i moved to
the philippines because i got a job
offer down there to work at a movie
studio
all right but then i was there for about
six months and i went back to hong kong
right doing my stuff but then
then and this is mainly doing like
martial arts and martial arts acting
voice acting and stunt right of
everything yeah
yeah well throughout acting school
you'll learn to be an actor and you
learn voice acting
right and then i was a martial artist so
like stunts off the back of that right
right
so then um but then so then okay go 2006
6 7 8 i'm there end of 2008 along comes
that global financial crisis
that wipes out everything i had going on
yeah right i'm like all right well
nothing to go back to at home
now there's nothing here what am i gonna
do all right
and i made the logical choice of
realizing the way to solve all my
problems was to become a cross-dressing
pro wrestler and heavy metal singer
okay okay so how did you how did you
come to that realization
like this is
let's take it one step at a time right
like so have you always had i assume
you've always had a fascination towards
wrestling
uh yeah so a martial artist obviously
yeah yeah and also
performer and stunt man so really pro
wrestling's a small skipper yeah yeah
yeah
i was always interested in wrestling
when i was younger but um here just due
to where i lived in adelaide and where
the wrestling gyms were they were miles
away so i never had the chance to
actually do it did you watch like wwe
yeah but there wasn't when i was at the
age to watch all that it wasn't on tv
very readily in adelaide it was on like
1 30 in the morning yeah yeah
thursday yeah so it's like you know well
only the naughty kids
wwe sometimes yeah yeah but i'm um
you're of a different generation than i
i think without giving up too many
things yeah the wrestlers you watched
are probably different from the ones
i mean to be frank i didn't really watch
a whole lot of wrestling
assume i watch wrestling yeah i mean i i
okay
my wrestling knowledge of like back you
know when i was like in teenage years
yeah all of it comes from all the wwe
games that my
neighbor used to have okay so like you
know be like back then when it was i
think it was still smackdown versus raw
yeah right like that kind of like level
so
it's like you know it's like very big i
wouldn't call myself a wrestling fan but
that's around the time
when i was getting access to this 1 30
in the morning right
right but you had to have foxtel to be
able to watch the damn wrestling i
didn't have foxtel yeah
foxtel was like uh like sky okay that's
why
like yeah like sky yeah yeah basically
yeah but in australia sky is that
conservative news network don't say sky
because it's
too many people use the same words for
their media outlets
so wait okay so then i want to know then
if that's the case okay so you're like
so okay so you're like into wrestling
and you're like okay it's just a
logical you know progress to go into
wrestling yeah so then so like how do
you
okay i've always wondered because i knew
i know a few people who like used to be
pro wrestlers or currently do progress
okay
how do you even start to get into an
industry like that well you go and you
go to wrestling school
so you go to a wrestling gym and you'll
do a try out to see whether or not they
will train you
and if they accept you then they accept
you and they start training you right
what do they look for what's like what's
like the audition
well you need to have um you know
physically you need to be able to handle
the physical stuff yeah
and then you know from a um i guess a
presentation a performance perspective
you need to have uh
some level of aptitude in that
absolutely
yeah you don't necessarily need to be
trained in anything already but if
you're super shy and you can't handle
being in front of an audience it's not
going to work out great right
wrestling is generally speaking about
larger than life characters yeah yeah
yeah and many dresses yeah yeah or man
in dresses
how did you go from that to moving to
japan then so
okay so uh financial crisis
uh all the work's gone uh but around
that time i started wrestling in hong
kong because there was a gym that was
accessible to me for the first time
started wrestling um started training
a month later i caught on fairly quickly
because the techniques are not that
different from stunts right
right a month later i had my first match
and so we're getting ready yeah
that's too fast yeah anyone who's
training for care
a month is too fast i feel a month is
too fast for any training
let's go from your first body slam to
doing in front of people
right so so is when you say
first wrestling match is like a whole
coordinated this you do this i do this
kind of thing or is it literally just
you
like how does that work i have no idea
um well sorry in wrestling it's uh
okay so there's like a system right
right once you learn the system
then you can work so if i know what i'm
doing if you i'm trained to the system
and you're trained to the system
you can never have like read the world
we can we can
we know that you figure out right um
okay sorry
it's all right it's all right connor
fine i don't know because
you know i mean you know because it's
it's an act but you know it's not an act
right but i don't i don't know what i
mean that wrestling is fake connor
so this is conor mcgregor right mma it's
the real thing
mcgregor well on top of the morning to
you i thought this was the joe rogan
experience
this is not the job connor what's going
on it's a podcast i was live
too
your last name is not mcgregor what
should i call you by your last name
ladybit is literally
in every
and i say this in the nicest way
possible is one of the hardest people to
work with
oh [ __ ]
like i just said like i literally just
said this man is like
destroying the set within jesus christ
of recording
my legs can't walk correctly
all right let's let's cut sorry